our old friend Tesla autopilot and it's
probably one of the most intelligent
real world AI systems in the world right
you followed it from the
beginning yeah it was one of the most
incredible robots in the world and
continues to be yeah and it was really
exciting and it was super exciting when
it
generalized became more than a robot on
four- Wheels but uh a real world AI
system that perceives the world yeah and
has can have potentially different
embodiments well I mean the really wild
thing about the anend training is that
it like it learns to read like you can
read science but we never taught it to
read
so yeah we never taught it what we never
taught it what a car was or what a
person was or a B
cyclist uh it
learned what what all those things are
what all the objects are on the road
um from video just from watching videos
just like humans I mean humans are
photons in control controls out like the
vast majority of information reaching
our brain is from our eyes um and you
say well what's the output the output is
our motor signals to
our sort of fingers and mouth in order
to
communicate
um protons in controls out the same is
true of the
car but by looking at the sequence of
images it's you've agreed with ilas
discover
recently where he talked about llm
forming a world model and basically
language is a projection of that world
model onto the sequence of yeah letters
and and you saying it finds order in in
in these things uh it
finds correlative
clusters and so so doing it's like
understanding something deep about the
world yeah which is
like it's beautiful that's how our brain
works yeah but it's it's beautiful in
controls out your all nuts are able to
understand that deep meaning in the
world and so the question is how far can
it go and it does seem everybody's
excited about llms so in the space of
self supervised learning in the space of
text yeah um it it seems like there's a
deep similarity between that and what
Tesla autopal is doing is it to you
basically the same but
coning they
converging I wonder who gets there
faster understand having a deep
understanding of the
world or they just will naturally
converge they're both headed towards
AGI um the TA approach is much more
computer efficient it has to be be cuz
we were constrained on this this you
know we only have 100 Watts
um and an in 8
computer 144 trillion operations per
second which sounds like a lot but it's
kind of small potatoes these
days at in ag but it's understanding the
world at in
ag it's only 256
values but there the path to AGI might
have much more significant impact
because it's
understanding it'll it'll faster
understand the real world than will llms
and there for be able to integrate with
with the real humans in the real world
faster they're both um going to
understand the world but I think Tesla's
approach is fundamentally more computer
efficient it had to be there was no
choice like our brain is very computer
efficient very energy efficient so
think of like what what is our brain
able to do um you know there's only
about 10 watts of higher brain function
not counting stuff that's just used to
control our body um the thinking part of
our brain is less than 10 watts um and
that 10 those 10 watts can still produce
a much better novel than a 10 megawatt
GPU cluster so there's a six order of
magnitude difference
there um I mean the the AI is thus far
gotten to where it is via Brute Force
just throwing massive amounts of compute
and and massive amounts of power at it
so this is not where where it will end
up um you know in general with any given
technology you first try to make it work
and then you make it
efficient so I think we'll find over
time that these models
get smaller are able to
do produce a sensible output with far
less compute far less
power um Tesla is arguably ahead of the
game on that front because um it has
we've just been forced
to try to understand the world with a
100 watts of
compute um and there are a bunch of sort
of fundamental functions that we kind of
forgot to include so we have to run them
in bunch of things in
emulation um we fixed fixed a bunch of
those with hard rare 4 and then hard
rare 5 will be even better
um but I it does appear at this point uh
that the call be able to drive better
than a human even with Hardware 3 and
100 wats of
power and
really if we really optimize it could be
probably less than 50
wats what have you learned learned
about uh developing Optimus about
applying integrating this kind of real
world AI into the space of robotic
manipulation just humanoid
robotics what are some interesting tiny
or big things you've understood I was
surprised at the fact that we had to
develop every part of the robot
ourselves um that there were no offthe
shelf Motors Electronics
sensors like we had to develop
everything um we we couldn't we couldn't
actually find a source of electric
motors for any amount of
money um so it's not even just efficient
inexpensive it's like anything there's
not a
no the ACT everything everything has to
be yeah designed from scratch we tried
hard to find anything that was because
you think of how many electric motors
are made in the world there's like tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands of
electric motor
designs
um none of them were suitable for a
humanoid robot literally
none so we had to develop our own design
design it specifically
for for what a humanoid robot needs how
hard was it to design something that's
can be Mass manufactured could be
relatively inexpensive I mean if you
compare Boston Dynamics Atlas it's a
very
expensive robot it is designed to be
manufactured in the same way they would
make a car and I think ultimately we can
make Optimus for less than the cost of a
car it should be CU if you look at
the mass of the robot is much
smaller and the car has many actuators
in
it the car is more actuators than the
robot but there is uh the actuators are
kind of interesting in a humanoid robot
robot with the fingers so Optimus has
really nice hands and fingers you know
yeah and they could do some interesting
manipulation soft soft touch robotics I
mean one of the tests goals I have is
can can it pick up a needle and a thread
and thread the needle just by looking
how far away are we from that just by
looking just by looking maybe a
year although I go back to I'm
optimistic on time the work that we're
doing in the car will translate to the
robot the perception or the also the
control the no the controls are
different but the the video in controls
out um the the car is robot on four
wheels the the the Optimus is a robot
with hands and legs so you can just
they're they're very they're very
similar so the entire Machinery of the
learning process yeah and to end is just
you just have a different set of
controls ofus we'll figure out how to do
things by watching videos